de la marche dans une eau à 28° un bien
fou pour ses curistes qui viennent
soulager leurs jambes
une première cure pour certains et pour
d'autres un retour pour se refaire une
santé les soins m'apporte pas du bien
être cinq ou six mois dans l'année
après avoir comparé avec une autre cure
thermale je suis revenue ici je suis
bien accueillis tout le temps mais
ça fait 6 g
et là je me fais me this way c'est mon
petit cadeau de chaque année avec 5400
curistes l'an dernier qui venait surtout
du nord-est de la france
les termes de luxeuil sont reconnus et
conseiller dans le traitement de la
rhumatologie de l'afld les movie et de
la gynécologie un investissement soutenu
pour un site qui ne cesse de croître
aujourd'hui on est la première station
de bourgogne franche comté et puis des
ambitions de se dire que d'ici 10 15 ans
on aura donc redoublera de nouveau notre
nombre de curistes pour essayer
d'arriver à 10000 il ya 40 ans luxeuil
c'était une station de mille curistes
même si l'udc cei est une des plus
anciennes stations de france puisqu'elle
en l'an 700 on avait déjà du thermalisme
sur le même site
soixante salariés travaillent au terme
et il est dit que dit curistes
représente un emploi dans la ville un
atout non négligeable pour la ville de
luxeuil les bains
on est aux environs de 12 millions
d'euros de retombées économiques
annuelles et 300 emplois directs sans
compter une multitude d'emplois
indirects dont qui font vivre bons
nombres de luxeuil de gens du pays de
luxeuil autour du terrorisme autour du
thermalisme
c'est une véritable vitrine également
pour la haute saône puisque c'est la
seule station thermale dans le
département alors une saison qui débute
pour se terminer le 30 novembre prochain